hey guys welcome to the series on how to
make a YouTube playlist up using the
YouTube API okay guys so here we have
the applet we're gonna be creating today
simple YouTube playlists app that pulls
in all the information using the YouTube
API including these thumbnails here the
title description even the video so
basically what it does is I've created a
playlist here on my YouTube channel and
the link for all the stuff I give you
links will be in the description and
there's 12 videos in here so this
playlist will be pulled into our app you
can see the order is the same in our app
here I always pulled in using the
YouTube API right cool so let's get
started so the first thing we want to do
we probably want to create a central div
here in the middle where it's white and
then this Davy's built into sections so
there's a header another section and the
main bit so let's build that section so
jump into you to dip into code pen and
the first thing I just want you to check
that you have a few things ready so jump
into the settings cog at the side of the
CSS and make sure you have normalize and
autoprefixer on these will just help
your the app just look the weight should
in different applications save and close
that and we're ready to go
so let's create this central div and
we're using M it again so instead of
writing div div with a class calls
container etc we're just gonna say dock
container and hit the tab on and there
we go we've written the devout followers
so inside the container we have the
header where the logo sits so we can
just say
header tab and we have a section where
the video six so we're gonna say section
then gonna say hashtag video and hit tab
and ma has given us a section tag
because we just said section there was
no dot or hash e in front of that but
then we followed it with hash video so
that said hey the ID is gonna be video
because hashes ID then we're gonna have
a main section right welder all the list
type items are so let's start by giving
the background its color so body we want
a background color of EEE so very
slightly darker white basically that's
because our container is white so let's
give it a width of 560 pixels let's give
it height of 100 view hey a viewport
height VH right and what that means is
all the visible area of the screen so
not when you scroll down our sideways
this is the viewport this is what you
can view so Honda VH is a hundred
percent of the screen and V W is view
with so that's one hundred percent with
ways all right we still can't see it so
let's give it a background color but
gonna call it over hash ffff so that's
the same as saying hash F free time I
have six times are writing white so now
we can see we've got a little bit a bit
of a block here on the Left let's put
that down the middle by same margin we
want zero margin at the top and bottom
but on the left and right we want it to
be the same so that would century
because they have to be the same so
that's Auto cool
so the next thing we should do is
probably let's put this logo in here
right so I'll have the link to the logo
in the description I'm going to copy it
here so we're gonna say IMG because we
use an Emmet we want it to have a class
so don't logo this is so in CSS we can
change it then hit tab we want them to
fill out the SRC with the actual
location of the image so here's the
location for me and it's a bit too big
so let's change that let's go to logo in
the CSS let's change it to with a
hundred and twenty pixels my desk also
that's getting better but if you notice
on here when we scroll up this and the
header the video on the header stays in
the same place right and if we did that
now you can see the YouTube is
disappearing so let's fix that before we
go any further so I'm just gonna go
above the logo and say yo header tags I
want you to stay fixed to the top so we
say position fixed right doesn't look
like it did that much but if I scroll
now and I'm scrolling you can see the
scroll bar here
it's stay where it is right okay so
let's make this image Center sent
centralized we can do that by saying
text-align:center right he says
ah so we need to give it so it's
centered so if I go background color red
you'll see the actual background of it
is only a small amount and we want it to
be the full width right so we want it to
be also 560 pixels because when you make
something fixed you're taking out of
Florida document so normally with a div
you go header main and it carry on going
down the page one after another
what fixed is done is is taken out at
flow and it's just saying hey I'm just
going to stay at the top because you
told me to so with that it has got rid
of its width that it would inherit from
the container it was in right so
anything can inherit has got rid of so
width 560 pixels and now that text align
works like if I take it off goes across
there because now it knows what width it
has fine that's good for now so let's
put in that video right and the way you
can get this video embedded you can do
straight from YouTube so if I jump into
YouTube this is our playlist and I click
on one of the videos and this is with
any video right you go down here to
share and click on that you'll see this
embed and this is the whole link this is
the whole code even to what we need so
you can copy out there or I'll link it
as well or whatever video you want and
we can just basically inside this
section of the idea of video we can just
paste that in there right but it looks a
little bit funny right so the video is
scrolling and we don't want that to
happen
and
this header is kind of sitting on top of
it
so why don't we make this section the
section the same position fixes the
header well it also needs to width and
text align doesn't really matter to it
so why don't we just tag onto here by
saying : section so now these have both
the same things going on and then I
scroll the video stays there but you can
see that now the headers disappeared
underneath it because in the HTML the
section has come after the header so it
says well we're the same we're both
fixed the hierarchy is the same but I
actually come will lower down than you
in the HTML so I'm gonna sit on top of
you so the way we can fix that is say ok
header so yeah ok section we actually
need you to start lower down the page so
we want you to add the top be 50 pixels
away from the top and there we go let's
let it breathe a little bit how about we
give some padding to this YouTube logo
so let's go to duck logo say pad in 10
pixels and it actually has 10 pixels on
the left and the right as well but it
doesn't affect it so we're gonna leave
it saves us right into how like zero
pixels here right it's the same thing we
don't need it so 10 pixels looking
pretty good
I scroll and it stays where it stays
where it is right that's important okay
so now on to the main section what we
want to do here is we'll need an image
and the details so we could probably fit
these in just one container and split
this container too right so we're gonna
do that very semantically and jump into
our HTML and we're going to create an
article and hit tab
an article is just a very semantic way
of basically saying this is kind of the
main container of what holds our content
you can use in different ways but for
this where we're going to use multiple
articles so we know what an article like
so what we need to do with article then
we need to give it two things it needs
an image so IMG with a class of four hit
tab and we're gonna fill in that sauce
I've got a link here I'll leave you the
link in the description and put that
right here in the sauce and now you see
a problem we'll carry on we also want a
container a div with a class of details
it's AB and then this div will have h4
that's going to hold that title and the
P so the P tab and that's going to be
our description so I this gription right
so that's all the article needs to have
right so it needs an image tag inside an
article and a div with details inside of
a table as you can see it's right up
here now and this the header doesn't
seem to have a background so there's a
couple of things we need to do jump into
our CSS file its header
this is header and section we can just
give it a background color of that white
color which is free apps hash tag free
apps now it's disappeared but we know
the article still hiding back here so
you got to remember the article
the main section this main section here
is in the the
the page till now the section and this
header have jumped out of the main flow
so effectively main is the first thing
on the page that's still in the flow so
that is at the top as well so what we
can do then for that is we can give main
some padding to bring it down
looks like main carry brackets padding
and we want to give it something like so
it's got a big padding from the top so
it's gonna be like three hundred and
seventy pixels from the top right but we
also want it to have some on the sides
so 18 pixels and we don't want the
bottom to be 370 so we can just give the
bottom 10 pixels and if we end it there
18 pixels will work for left and right
because we haven't specified the left
side after the bomb and that's fine to
do right so now it's actually visible
the image is a little bit big so why
don't we deal with that why don't we say
the form because we give the image a
class of form we want you to be height
of 70 pixels all right
that's looking pretty good and you can
do it with if you want but I think
because some of the thumbnails are
different aspect ratios so I think it
just looks better that they're all the
same height so that's what I did on this
so we're getting there were getting
closer now now we need this div
container here to be the side here so
we're gonna do that by jumping into
article and we need to say yo article
why don't you display as a flexbox
container display flex and as you can
see it's coming to side of it
it's a little bit disjointed right this
is kind of down the reason is because
these have their own margins and
padding's the P and H file so let's pull
them off now let's let's do some styling
of the typography and we're gonna do at
the top because it's I like to have my
typography out of the way at the top so
the way we do this we're going to use
something in s CSS it's called a mixing
and basically what that does is it gives
you some pre-arranged code which then
you can use over and over again so it's
kind of like a variable but in CSS so to
do this we want to basically say we're
creating a mixin so app mixing then
we're going to give it a name so we want
to create a section call code called
font base which we can then import into
multiple CSS blocks so we want to take
off the padding right and we want to
take off the margin and we want to do a
few of things we want to give it a line
height of 1.3 which is basically if this
paragraph carried on going down the
distance between the actual bottom of
this line and the top of the next line
that's the line high so we've just
increased it effectively by point free
and we want to then say font weights 600
to make it bold now you know it's
nothing happened here that's because we
haven't called font base so let's do
that
we're saying hey page four we want you
to be to include font base so the way
you do it you say at in clue so you
including it then just call the name
front base you can see that just jumped
up then because now it has the padding
and everything else taking off
the P tag we also want that to be
including our font base so include font
base and what we does
boom they go but now they're the same
and in our visual this is gray and
smaller so let's do grain smaller and
let's do that now so color which is how
you get the font color just kind of call
it gray cuz I know that's a good color
and we want to make the text smaller so
this a font size 0.7 Ram they are
smaller and we use in RAM which is the
relative elements as relative to the
browser default size so most browsers
are 16 pixels default font size so we're
saying be point 7 of that like okay so
it's not looking bad let's add a few
more of these articles anyhow it's just
copy and paste this article copy hi so
just copy and paste some notes down the
page here we go so we need to now start
adjusting some some padding's right so
the way we're going to do that here's
our article so if we jump down to our
article article is only display flex at
the moment so it needs a few things we
want this this details to sit in the
middle of kind of the whole article so
we can say a line items center and that
that aligns centrally so you just move
down we need to give it some of that
padding so we need to say padding we
want to be padded at 8 pixels at the top
and 12 pixels left and right
so that's looking a bit closer now we
need a little bit more gap here notice
how we have a little gap here so we want
to do that on the video description
right so we'll just go underneath the
foam to keep in the right thing so we
want to say dot details we want to say
you know dot details give us some
padding you can give us eight pixels at
a top and bottom and 22 pixels at the
left and right side which pulls away
cool it's looking very close so now we
need to just do this hover right have
this nice little blue hover over it so
we can go into article and we can use
another CSS helper which is and/or
ampersand hover that basic ASAE's
article wall we placed the end so in CSS
you would normally say article hover
you'd do it that way you don't need to
do that M s CSS you can just say and
hover and it knows you're dealing with
whatever you're inside of because we're
still inside of these curly brackets
right so and hover
so the articles hover we want to have a
border of two pixels solid and we want
this red color which is hash FF 90999
right so now when we hover there you go
but it's looking a little funky when we
they're kind of moving about and that's
because you're adding a border when you
hover over it so yeah adding to the size
of the article so we can do is just say
border this is on the article itself two
pixels solid why
oh we can use that ffff it's totally up
to you it's the same so now it already
has a board on it but you can't see it
so when we hover over it it doesn't jump
about we need to round the edges of this
little red container and our thumbnails
so let's do that I say border - radius 8
pixels for this little red thing there
you go it's looking pretty cool and we
want to do that on our thumbnail as well
so i say border - radius let's say 4
pixels on this one okay so far pixels on
that one and it's looking pretty good
we're pretty close to the end I think
the only thing I want to do is just want
to add I just want to add a margin 0 all
to my article just so it's gonna always
be in the middle of that main container
and it should be anyway but I'm just to
assure right ok and there you have it
we have a scrollable list the video
stays where is the header stays where it
is and you can scroll down obviously we
don't have to click functionality in yet
that's gonna be down in the JavaScript
and a jQuery in the next video in the
next video we're going to actually look
at how to set up the API how to get an
API key and how to make the calls and
make all this information dynamic does
mean we pull a bit of this information
out of here
so you've wasted your time a little bit
but not too much cause when the result
comes in you'll see how cool is okay
guys so quick refresher this is the
application that we're making simple
little app
can click on the items and the video
changes at the top all this information
is pulled dynamically from YouTube and
how we did that was I created a little
playlist on YouTube called YouTube and
I've linked that as well so you can get
straight to that playlist and this has
12 videos in it and what we do in we're
actually saying to YouTube hey go get us
playlist we want the image the title and
the description and some video
information so we can display it so let
me show you first the YouTube Doc's so
here we are the link for this is in the
description as well and we're
interesting playlist items and the list
of those playlist items you can see on
the left here but you can see there's
all sorts here there's channels comments
you can get comments from them
subscriptions from nails lots of
information we can pull from the YouTube
API so what we're going to do is win a
whole play so I'm going to click on
JavaScript here and I know there's
different bits of information you can
get I know we just want to snip it so
I'm just going to say you have to take a
snippet we've got twelve videos but we
can bring back 20 videos to our playlist
and what we need to do is if we put in
our playlist ID here which is this for
me I'll link I'll put this in the link
as well so you can use it and if we
click execute you can see here create a
weather app using an API part one HTML
go down all the phone nail stuff here
again part two here and all the videos
are listed here so it's made that
request for us in the documentation so
we can actually see if this is going to
work and if the information coming back
is what we actually want and it is so
that's cool and it sends that request to
this URL here
so welcome do the same and to do that
first of all we need the YouTube API
enabled and we also need an API key
so effectively a password right so how
we do that is I've given you a link to
this in the in the description we need
to go to let me find this really quick
we're gonna go to this which is you
developers console right yeah so it
should when you come here on the link on
the developers console link be something
like this you might not have all these
boxes but don't we just yet what I need
you to do is next to us is Google API s
new project I need to click on there
yours probably doesn't say new project
but whatever is it aside of Google API
is click on it and click this little
plus symbol right here right because you
want to create a new project type
whatever your project name is in I'm not
gonna do it because I already have one
click create then then I'll create it
for you there might be a little bit of a
time delay you might have to wait for it
to go through the process of it but I'll
do a minute or so you should be able to
then select your project from in here so
I'm gonna select the new project and
then we want to enable the YouTube API
so we do that by just clicking enable
api's and services right here and
searching so I'm going to search YouTube
and this for API say we want YouTube
data API v3 right because this is just
getting providers information form such
as videos playlists etc so click on that
one and click the big
you enable born they'll do this spinny
thing and it'll take a while to enable
it again but once it's enabled what we
need to do is we then need to get an API
key which is effectively the password so
if you watch the last video we did the
weather app video you will know that we
could just send the request and get
information back this time we don't have
that ability we need to send with it our
information so on the left-hand side you
can see credentials so just click that
you see I've got one listed here already
you can create credentials right here
this little blue thing and you want to
create API key so click on that and
there's a new API key right so you can
just copy that out there and that's what
we're gonna be using okay so where do we
start
let's jump into our code and let's make
this request let's just move this
jeaious right up here so we're using
jQuery so make sure we've got jQuery
installed by clicking the little cog on
the side of the j/s which is a settings
cog go to quick add at the bottom at the
bottom you see I put in my recent jQuery
you might have it down here
jQuery there so click on that save and
close and jQuery is installed ready to
use right so how do we start this off
well we need to stay off of a container
for jQuery to working so say dollar for
a jQuery we're about to use you so seen
when the document
so as the page is a document when that
document is ready I want you to do
something so doing something is a
function clearly brackets and that's the
container for jQuery right so now we can
start running jQuery stuff in
just plain JavaScript which makes the
API call a lot easier so what we want to
do first is we want to just set it up so
we have the information our fingertips
to use later so let's set it up for
using our API key so let's create a
variable called key and what we wanted
to do is we want to just copy and paste
so copy and paste from your credentials
your key we want to copy and paste that
straight into our document into our
variable here that's my key now we also
need the playlist ID to send it to right
so let's go and get that playlist ID so
if I go to the playlist so this is the
actual playlist page look the way you
can get the ID is going to the address
bar at the top and the last little bit
which says list equals after the equals
that's the playlist ID so let's copy
that out there I'll put a link in the
description for you let's call this bar
play oops
play list I D equals and put in quotes
there we go playlist ID now the last bit
of information is where the API call
where the API call is right what we
actually send in the API call - so we go
back to the documents the YouTube Docs
and that was here look so we filled all
this stuff in before this is the request
HTTP request I'll link this in the
description also and what we can do is
then just copy that I'll make another
variable called URL and we'll set it in
between
quotes and there we go that's our three
bits of information ready to get
everything else going right in with
these we've got one actual piece of
information we also need to send with it
which is the options so if you look back
here we we are sending a few bits of
information we're sending snippet which
basically gets those things like foam
nail title etc and Max results 20
whatever and the playlist ID and when
you send all this information to here
along with your API key Denon will send
the response but all these are options
so we actually need to send that with a
request so let's create another variable
and in this variable color options is
going to be an object because this is
what the YouTube API expects to receive
so it's an object and the object is
going to have a few things so it's gonna
have that part and that part was called
snippet right it also needs our key
which we have at the top so we're just
basically popping it into here
so key and we're gonna access the key
variable so this place here
it needs to know how many results we
want so max results up sorry Max results
we said 20 but you know we have 12 in
our players but its maximum search fine
and then we also need to know which
playlist it is go into it's going to get
the information for so all the stuff on
the left is stuff
YouTube has specified the names off so
you see it all here
you know parameters here playlist ID Max
result
tells you all about it in the docs and
we're just basically sending why once so
playlist ID is coming straight from this
variable right so onto the request so we
want to say hey let's let's click
function and it's going to load the vids
right so it's going to load our videos
load vids and what that actually is
gonna do it's gonna send a request it's
a dollar so we're using jQuery here so
saying hey jQuery you have a function
called get Jason let's use that it's
already already built in it's a pre
pre-made code well I need a few bits of
information with this so YouTube needs a
few bits of information it needs a URL
which we have we've already got out so
URL I also need a bunch of options
including the key etc so we have that so
we're gonna say options and then it's
going to take that from that variable
and after after I've sent the request
you give me the options I'm gonna return
something so I need to do something so
doing is a function so I'm going to do
something after I return the data but
you need to tell me what you want this
data to be called so within this
parentheses we're going to tack the data
we can call this whatever we want but it
needs to be able to access it we need a
name to be able to access it so let's
console.log this data right we also need
to call the function so call it load
vids so we're calling above it and the
function is underneath right let's see
what happens
so we'll inspect the element so we can
get to the console you're going that
console I just need to get two logs so
here we are logs zoom in you see right
here there's an object if we open this
object you can see oh there's items in
here oh using form 0 to 11 so there's 12
items so this is going to be our
information right snip it there we go we
asked for that and it's telling us our
child tiled channel tile the post
create a web app thumbnails are in here
as well video IDs in here so this has
given us everything we need right here
so what should we do first
why don't we we'll just close this off
why don't we dynamically change this
video to the very first video in the
playlist so instead of right now in the
HTML like this we can now get rid of the
iframe so delete the iframe from your
HTML because where are you gonna create
that dynamically from the API so how to
do that well we need it to be a new
function right so we're going to call
this I guess function
function main vid and this main vid
function is basically gonna find the
container for that which is section with
an ID of vid so it's gonna find that and
then it's gonna inject something into it
so let's say hey jQuery dollar symbol
find something called video yes cause
hash tag video so find something called
hash video what I want you to do is I
want you to change the HTML that's
within those tags to something something
new right so I'm gonna use backticks to
do this make sure I've properly
corrected from here so contracts and
basically backticks is allows us to
inject variables directly into into the
string rather than having to close the
string add a plus sign add a variable
add another plus sign open a string up
backticks not quotes there backticks
lets us just do that lets us even have
spaces of line breaks and it doesn't
affect it so let's just copy and paste
our iframe from our HTML into the
document right that's a bit of a long
thing so a kind of call now right so I'm
just gonna get rid of this playlist
information here actually so it's
actually ready to run so we just need to
run this main main video function from
inside here
so basically saying make the API call
then load this function called main vid
there you go
then once main videos run find the video
section and inject this HTML but this
isn't dynamic yet right because we have
this hard-coded ID here so what we need
to do is and this is why we use
backticks
delete after it says embed forward slash
delete that bit of code to the quotes
right delete that and i want you to add
dollar symbol curly brackets ID just
make sure you clearly brackets end up
closing so now it's looking for a
variable called ID so we need to supply
it so what we need to do is we need to
send ID to it so we're sending ID then
we're gonna name it here saying yo
you're gonna receive something called an
ID so you can use it now we need to find
the ID of let's say the first let's say
the second one cause it's different
color we're gonna find d actually no
we'll do the first one we need to find
the ID of the first video in the
playlist so the way we do now is we say
create a variable called ID and set that
equal to data now we need to go find out
where it is so inspector on let's go to
console is my logs again so data is
object because this is what we named it
so this is our very root element so data
I mean to go into items this is it
because items is an array it's not an
object so the 0 of right
in Delray dan this is not the video ID
he's going to snip it then we need to go
to resource ID and video ID so it's
quite a long path so let's see if I
hundred data dots snippet dot after our
data dot items
was it items add to zero of position
then we want to jump inside to snip it
then there was the resource ID then
there was the video ID right and that's
what we want and they go so we created a
variable called ID which has got the
video ID passed it to main vid the main
vid here has used it within the string
so that's pretty cool right we're
getting that dynamically now okay so the
next thing to do we need to get all
these filled out so we need to kind of
say hey for each item in the array we
want to do something so how we're gonna
do it we want to loop through each item
in that array so let's create another
function so that's the main video
function let's create a function called
results loop all right what results loop
is gonna do is it's gonna basically add
each one of these pre-made so it's not
going to inject the thumbnail then
inject a tie or an injected description
it's gonna make this up here then put it
in so we're gonna make the HTML up in
here so let's do that so with
just gonna copy I'm gonna cut one of
these articles out so cut an article
then you can actually delete every of
one of the articles right we don't need
the articles anymore so we've got one in
our clipboard so what the results loop
does is it says hey I want you to select
the main container so do nano jQuery so
select the main container what I need
you to do is change T this is what not
this is not what we're doing we're not
changing from the HTML but I'll show you
I'll show you what you might think so we
want to change the HTML using those back
tics instead of quotes couple new lines
and we want you to add this article
thing right so if we call results loop
now so we want to do the API call change
the main video and once we change the
main video we then want to add stuff to
that that main section that's how we
call the result results
I think loop from inside our call there
you go it's added one of those fingers
so what we actually want it to do is we
want to say like okay so for each one of
these items we want you to add another
one and another one
right so the results loop needs to fill
this information out with it's dynamic
data so let's send all the data to
results loop so then results loop let's
say look you're getting this data
now Rizal sloop wants to run through
these things so it needs to create its
own thumbnail so let's call var form and
set that equal to well let's have a look
inspect element so console let's have a
look where it is so we need to go inside
an item array and the full nail is
inside in side items size snippet
aside from nails right and we're going
to take the the medium one I think yeah
medium then its URL by its it's quite
long path so the thumbnail is called and
we want to basically go into the data
now we need to go into an item then we
need to go into the snippet then into
the from nails then into the medium
medium-well medium then into URL now
there's a problem with this so let's try
and replace this URL of the thumbnail
which is in the sauce tag using you know
Billy tip using dollar symbol curly
brackets then putting the form in there
then close curly brackets if you haven't
closed them now hasn't done it and the
reason it's not done it is because item
needed a position right it was in an
array because it's multiples of these
things so if I did give it a position of
zero it would pull that in so it's not
the main there were from data item the
0th position where icon one here
snippet item medium URL how I expect on
this so object items deserve off item
snippets okay so items there we go
so that will work right but I have to
specify the location so what we need to
do is for doing this for one item you
don't want to be copying and changing
this one we can use for each loop or in
jQuery is just called an each loop so
let's sell that each loop
so we're saying hey jQuery for each this
is a jQuery jQuery billing function
JavaScript does the same for each so I
saying for each data so the data gave me
so for each of the datums data in the
items array now items array has multiple
as has 12 right so we're saying for each
of those 12 I want you to do something
as a function right so this is our
function what I want you to do is I is
the number you want so 0 1 2 our way to
11 in our case I want you to go through
and rename the mall called item now so I
can access them saying item so let's
take this variable for Col phone let's
move this inside and let's also take
this main with the dot HTML right we'll
take this cut that will go inside here
right
so still doing the same thing but why
don't we place this zero we don't need
anymore we need to now say hey y'all
ready looping foodies items right so
I'll let you do that so instead of
writing data item zero if we just like
item that's changed now there's only
change once so effectively it's looping
through each of the items and changing
it in HTML so on the 11th time that's
the last one so that's the last thing it
does we don't want that to happen this
is what I was saying earlier we want not
change the inner HTML we want to append
a new bit of that on to the Dom each
time so change HTML to dot append see
what it does there we go
so now we need to fix that but now we
have all the fun nails at least so now
we have the thumbnails let's do it for
everything else so let's carve our title
we want to set a title equals to item
don't snip it dot title because that's
where it is in that object when we tour
look in the console so now title is that
why don't we change what's in between
the h4 tags let's delete where we wrote
title dollar symbol curly brackets title
and just make sure you finish with curly
brackets you see all the titles are now
dynamically here right
same with description let's do that so
VAR d es c equals item dot Snippets dot
description
alright then let's go into the P tag
delete everything within the P tag
dollar sign curly brackets des C closing
curly brackets and they'll have it but
they're giant right we don't want that
much of a description in these things so
we can use JavaScript to remove
everything over a hundred characters
right and how we do that is we say go to
our desk variable and at the very end
just before the semicolon just type dot
sub sub string
I'm sorry lowercase sub string and it
needs two arguments he needs to know
where it starts so it starts at the very
first letter zero and for how long so
100 100 letters now yeah we've cut it
down dramatically now so the only thing
left to do is when we click on one of
these because at the moment doesn't do
anything we need to update that video
and we actually need to pull some
information from the API so it knows
where to go so let's let's do that so
let's say we're gonna actually say hey
when the main is clicked on find out
what has been clicked on it in that main
and change the video so it looks a
little something like this so select
select the thing called main and when is
click so dot on so this is basically
saying it's an event what event is it
going to be so when it's clicked you can
do something as a function
right and let me show you this so let's
do alert hello
hopefully lets me do this in code pen so
when I click on the main should say
hello right there you go
and it's gonna go through it
11 times maybe I didn't expect that so
we don't want that to happen right
because we could say when the article is
clicked on but we we don't want to add
multiple multiple event handlers for
each item because you don't know how
many items were gonna do and that's why
we're using main
so we're saying when we click on main
what I actually want you to do is I
wanted to dig down to find the article
element right because the article has
the information we won right
and don't forget that comma dere before
the function so we need to when it's
clicked on we need to send some
information back to the main video
function right because that's what
changes that video so we need to find
the ID of that video so whenever we
click on one of these we need to find
the ID of that video but we haven't
given these articles that ID so we need
to do that right so this is how we do
that in this article so in our main top
end we want to give it a class right
it's called class item right and
we also want to inject the video ID into
the article and this is how we do it we
are making something called a data key
and we want to say hey curly but dollar
symbol curly brackets vid and your curly
brackets and you quotes so what's
happening here is we have now made this
expert and calling for a vid variable so
let's create that valve it equals and
what does the vide call the Archie cause
the video ID right so let's let's put on
to item don't snip it dot resource I d
dot video I D now that's where the the
video ID is in if you can't so logged it
that's where it is right so now this day
a key holds the video ID so if we go
back to this event listen that we're
making where we can click on the main
you will dig down to the article and now
it's digged its way down to the article
we can point pull out that video ID
because it's stored in the data key of
the article right so let's create a
variable called ID an ID he wants to be
you want to basically select this
element so we clicked on it dip down to
the article so select this and select
this items basically this articles
element called data - key right to
select that de aqui right which will be
individual for each video and we could
then say why don't you alert
why don't we lower the ID so let's see
so hopefully this works so when I click
on this one it's giving me this ID lock
and it's gonna go for them it's gonna go
through it 11 times I can't do it dad so
that is because let's do it let's fix
this now show it that is because we have
movement in this main this is my fault I
should have been clearer so this whole
on click event handler event listener we
have written this inside this upend
right we were showing written inside
this each loop we don't want inside that
each loop in fact we want this just out
on its own so copy it so alert ID -
laughing you're a curly brackets and
parentheses and come on cut that out
alright so that was my bad
so that can actually live right down on
the bottom just leave your jQuery
container stuff clear so just go police
in this space and just copy and paste it
in there like looking better right cool
so now when I click on one of these it
shouldn't do it 11 times once there we
go so that's because I wrote this
accidentally still inside of this edge
loops I've seen okay each time I click
on the main oh sorry but when I click on
the main for each one of these items I
want you to alert and that's what it was
doing that's why kid going on I'm going
on so now we don't want to alert the ID
what we want to do is we want to call
this main video because
we can pass in an ID and the ID will
change and it will update the HTML it
will update the video right so let's
call it as call mein vid and let's send
that new variable this data key ascends
it in ace parentheses to that function
again this should be it should be very
close here so when I click on this here
we go now it's changing and that's
pretty much all there is to it
few little things I guess when we scroll
down we saw this you know the white
stuff is ended right so we can just go
into our CSS and I think this was
because we set a height of eh here so we
can take that off and there you go
straight to the bottom
no VH clicking through and they all work
we probably don't need the console log
now in where was it in when it comes
into our load fits we can delete that
you don't really have that in production
code there you go I hope that was easy
enough for you clear enough to follow so
we pulled in all the information we
needed to use in variables we sent the
request in functions load and the load
called it and we basically said hey
YouTube URL
here's your settings your options now
return me something called data with all
the information in then we call the main
vid which took the ID from the very
first video and loaded it this is main
rid of right underneath went to the HTML
and injected with the new ID from this 0
F position into it we then call the
results loop
we then call the results loop oh just
take our space and stuff and basically
the results loop chucking the data from
that API call and for each item it
created variables of what we needed
then appended to the main so didn't
change the main the whole HTML it added
to the main each time an article this is
the article add an article to it with
the dynamic data for each array item so
you know each in the items it was an
array had 11 I say had 12 different
items so go through that each time
putting these variables in place and
then when I click dig down to the
article find the data key with inside
this article then call that main video
again we've the new ID and that's why
old days okay guys I hope that wasn't
too difficult like I said earlier and I
hope you got a lot out of it please
comment subscribe and like the video
thanks for joining me and I'll see you
in the next video